on vous a senti ému tout à l'heure
lorsque vous avez parlé des anciens
combattants lorsque vous avez rencontré
ou si vous êtes allé le voit les voir
sur la plage qu'est ce qui représente
pour vous d'abord aujourd'hui ce moment
pour nous les remercier pour leur
sacrifice leur bravoure il ya 75 ans
mais c'est aussi une journée à réfléchir
comment le monde aurait pu être si le
jour j n'avait pas été réussie si si on
avait vécu une histoire différente et de
surtout de se souvenir qu'il faut pas
prendre pour acquis
ce qu'on a en tant de paix de liberté
même dans ces terres où on voit des les
conflits souvent on est dans un monde
extrêmement plaisir comparé à ce qu'on
se connaissait il ya 75 ans et on a
beaucoup parlé au cours des cérémonies
passé puisque je pense que ça va se
poursuivre pour celles à venir du devoir
de mémoire
on est dans une europe qui lui apparaît
de plus en plus de divisions ont
semble-t-il où les grands ensembles
compenser a qui commencent à bouger un
petit peu des alliances qui sont
peut-être plus aussi solide qu'avant
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire en termes
de responsabilité il faut se souvenir
qu'il ya toujours toujours des
changements toujours des tensions dans
le monde ce qui est important c'est que
les citoyens est conscient des défis du
passé et comment on peut faire pour
s'assurer qu'on ne fait pas les erreurs
du passé à ce niveau là il faut qu'on
soit conscient que c'est toujours plus
facile de diviser que de bâtir mais la
seule façon de créer un monde meilleur
de surmonter les obstacles
c'est de le faire ensemble donc cette
ces symboles qu'on a vu depuis deux
jours des paysages
et avec l'allemagne se rassembler pour
réfléchir au cours de l'histoire et et à
comment nous devons de continuellement
cherché à se comprendre et à travailler
ensemble pour créer la paix et la
stabilité
ça s'arrête jamais les anciens
combattants à qui on a parlé pas mal
d'entre nous ont parlé de leurs
inquiétudes vis-à-vis d'eux de montée de
certains d'idéologie justement des
divisions qui commençaient à apparaître
et ça leur rappelle des mauvais
souvenirs
est ce que vous vous êtes aussi un peu
inquiet rapport à ce qui se passe
actuellement
je pense qu évidemment de voir une
certaine montée de l'intolérance dans la
parc public sur l'internet surtout su
toujours une cause d'être préoccupés
parce qu'on sait que nos nos communautés
les plus résilientes c'est ceux qui ont
du respect les uns pour les autres
qu'ils comprennent que la diversité
c'est une source de force
au canada on est on est souvent appelée
à se souvenir d'à quel point on est
chanceux d'avoir un pays ouvert tolérant
axée sur le fait qu'on peut on peut
réussir seulement si on travaille
ensemble
évidemment on se retrouve dans une année
électorale et ils vont certainement
avoir des discours difficile et des
débats importants mais je sais que les
parties et surtout les canadiens veulent
voir des gens qui vont travailler
ensemble pour résoudre nos grands grands
enjeux pourquoi
plus jamais on vivent une époque comme
on a vécu il ya 75 ans un dernier mot
sur nos forces armées
vous avez dit dans votre secours que 13
ont les associe beaucoup aux casques
bleus
ça faisait longtemps qu'on les a pas vus
dans ce rôle là on les a vus nous au
mali même personnellement il ya quelques
mois
c'est quoi les prochains jours prochains
dont l'engagement dans ce sens là vous
voyez
vous voyez plus d'engagement comme ça on
continue comprendre et tous les
canadiens comprennent qu'on a un rôle à
jouer dans le monde les canadiens on est
extrêmement chanceux de vivre au canada
mais ça vient avec
avec cette chance une obligation de
faire ce qu'on peut pour améliorer le
sort d'autres qui n'ont pas cette chance
là que ce soit par les opérations le
lieu que ce soit par le développement
que ce soit par la diplomatie
on est toujours là pour aider dans
différentes façons on a pris
l'engagement la commande d'une mission
de l'otan à bagdad
on est présent lettonie on est au mali
on va toujours chercher la meilleure
façon pour que le canada puisse
continuer à aider c'est ce que c'est
certainement ce que nous force à mener
armés veulent faire et c'est ce à quoi
les canadiens s'attendent
merci beaucoup le plaisir